hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today things going to be
getting a little bit personal because
it's time to talk about the impact of a
series that quite literally changed my
life and one that is quite possibly my
all-time favorite anime being Tengen
Toppa Gurren Lagann
and if you're not familiar with the
series first of all just watch it like
immediately it's absolute gold except
for one random episode where the
animators were high but even that's
forgivable in the grand scheme of things
but I'd also like to say right at the
outset that there will be spoilers in
this video and if you haven't seen
Gurren Lagann I highly recommend that
you go in blind to start off with the
basic premise of the series follows two
teenagers being Simone or Shimon in
Japanese but apparently it's Simone in
English but in any case he is a timid
boy who prefers to keep himself out of
trouble and then there's Carmina a brash
fool who is seemingly Simone's polar
opposite and the series follows their
journey to escape from their underground
village and explore the surface world to
the sky outer space and even beyond
involving heavily stylized battles in
mechs of you know questionable logic
simple enough I suppose
kind of but this property went
absolutely insane and unleashed an
unstoppable wave of potential into the
world thanks primarily to the
partnership of Hiroyuki imaishi and
Kazuki Nakajima who would go on to work
on a couple of other projects together
which I also loved but the prime example
of which being killed a kill but what
these two brought to this story amongst
many other things was an overwhelming
sense of optimism and empowerment a
future which i think is echo quite
strongly in their other collaborations
but this was the first time that I've
really had such a taste of this potent
optimism and I have to say that all of
its epitomized in one of communist
classic quotes which I still use today
which is believed in the me that
believes in you and caminar essentially
uses to artificially boost Simone's
confidence because he knew that Simone
looked up to him and it's such a
brilliant phrase because nobody ever
knows how to react to it whenever I've
used it in real life
I've often gotten quite shocked
reactions and non anime fans often
praised me for my out-of-the-box
thinking which in reality is simply a
basic philosophy that I stole from an
animated man with incredibly blue hair
but why is all of this optimism talked
revelant well it's because I was
watching Gurren Lagann when it was first
airing which was while I was in my final
year of high school being 2007 and yes
that does make me old thank you for
noticing but the person I was back then
is radically different to Who I am now
I was an extremely introverted
anti-social generally depressed kid with
a deep distaste for the world in general
and no confidence in myself whatsoever
and what's worse is that while I was
watching and reading a whole ton of
other series at the time because you
know that was the only enjoyment I could
find in life living vicariously through
fictional characters but most of those
stories happen to be like really deep
and depressing properties think stuff
like Evangelion Trigon or even fate/stay
night generally darker more profound
themes that come at great expense to a
character often resulting in tragedy and
yeah I was also engaged in my optimistic
series like I was reading one piece
quickly at the time and honestly that
was a bit of a lifeline of joy for me
and still is however in 2007 everything
changed for the better
being the hardcore high school we buy
was I made it my mission to watch
anything and everything I could and
April brought us Tengen Toppa Gurren
Lagann and I was hooked from the very
first episode the art was incredibly
stylized in this super schmack manner
that really stood out from the more
quote-unquote I guess realistic stuff
I'd been watching with a great quirky
sense of humor and some pretty stunning
animation for its time in fact one
sequence I don't think I'll ever forget
is during episode 1 when coming up and
Simone collided two sets of mole pigs
and in an event that I can only describe
as somehow created a vertical pig tower
to attempt to take them to the surface
makes no sense whatsoever but that was
really the beauty of it it didn't have
to make sense because it conveyed the
emotional intent very very effectively
perhaps even in a superior manner to
realism and this was an eye-opener to me
because even to this day I despise
dippin too much into realism in my own
creative work which is mostly theatre
design I very much prefer conveying a
powerful idea through something more
hyper realistic basically making emotion
and atmosphere palpable through design
and that is exactly what Guren margon
does so damn well throughout its run but
of course the key selling feature to me
was coming up because there was this
supremely confident never give up and
shoot for the stars personality kind of
guy and you know that was everything I
wanted to be and very much still want to
be if I'm honest with you the reality of
the situation back then though was that
I was the young Simone and that's why I
quite dislike Simone in the beginning
because if there was one thing I didn't
want to see in a series meant to help me
escape from the world it was me but at
the same time this connection to Simone
would be what triggered the change in my
life because going forward coming I was
to constantly show Simone that anything
was possible and push him far past his
limits taking him to the service world
and leading a resistance against the
beast men who oppressed humanity and you
know got to the point where every
victory for Simone felt like a victory
for me personally and that whole believe
in the me who believes in new philosophy
really got burnt into my soul and even
though I didn't have a real life figure
like coming and saying it to me I still
took on board the general idea which is
that your own self-doubt is irrelevant
just do the thing do the thing the best
you can and if you fail then so what but
if you never try you'll never succeed
and it is amazing just how the world
unlocked when I started looking at
things this way I took opportunities I
never would have considered before and I
even learnt to create my own
opportunities which is something that
has led to pretty much every major
career decision in my adult life and
once again all thanks to the words of a
2d character a 2d character that I
should say would go on to leave me in
shock after episode eight when seemingly
out of nowhere
kameena sacrificed himself and made a
grand exit from the series now to a high
school me this was incredibly shocking
because I simply wasn't used to stories
that allowed their main characters to
you know be mortal remember this was a
time before gamer Florence popularized
the nobody is safe style of storytelling
we see a lot today and lots of my
experience in anime was stuff like
Dragon Ball where death was effectively
meaningless and when it came to the daka
series well the main character would
always like die at the end if that was
going to happen
definitely not episode 8 and this event
left me really conflicted because on the
one hand I was used to tragic depressing
events as stated before but this was it
was kind of different
this wasn't just tragic it was actually
pure heroics there was something really
bittersweet about leaving comm unit
behind because I knew that he himself
was incredibly satisfied with how he had
used his life and also this method of
sacrifice would not be restricted coming
alone because towards the end of the
series several key characters all of
whom I loved went on to embrace doing
the impossible and channeling their
lives towards the constant evolution of
humanity and each and every one of them
was another iOpener of how even in its
most tragic moments life doesn't need to
be overcome with despair because there
is almost always a path forward but on
the other hand this initial sacrifice
had left me with Simone the guy I still
didn't really like because he was too
much like me but this is where things
really kicked into gear because it was
now time
for Simone to step up and prove to every
introverted self-doubting human being on
this planet that they too could do
something amazing or barring doing
something amazing something somewhat
decent something they could do something
and even that is enough and yes I know
it's just an anime but that's the effect
watching Simone Grohe had on me like he
went through a bit of a shinji phase but
a handful of episodes later that was
done
Simone took on bought everything that
Carmina had spouted at him and he made
the active choice to live the believe in
the me who believes a new lifestyle just
from a different perspective as he went
on to inspire I guess pretty much the
entire human race leading to the defeat
of the beastmen and the end of human
oppression and yes it's all fictional
but that doesn't make it any less
inspiring to see somebody that I
identify with become someone that I
could only dream of being and it's
obviously not just Simone either I spent
a lot of time talking about both he and
Carmina but the extended cast of Gurren
Lagann is one of the finest pool of
characters you will ever find in
storytelling and they all grow to this
point of insane optimism overcoming
their own personal barriers and reaching
incredible heights as a result in fact
even the established antagonists undergo
this transformation like fear a landlord
Janome and when they all come together
at the end well that's one of the most
satisfying conclusions to a story that I
have ever experienced speaking of there
you know what most series narrative Li
could and maybe would have stopped at
the point of defeating the beastmen but
that is the halfway point of Gurren
Lagann
and it had only just begun to showcase
its glory as Simone continued on his
path facing incredible hardships but
pushing through each and every one of
them and forging a path not only just
for Humanity but I guess sort of life in
general which in the case of this series
would be the spiral I forms as he went
on to replicate his success for the
beastmen and lead the charge against the
oppressors of the universe the anti
spirals and the maddening way in which
Gurren Lagann just kept one upping
itself constantly won me over as it
rapidly morphed from a small grounded
adventure between two teenagers to an
intergalactic space opera and somehow it
worked which I guess was through a
combination of its aesthetic qualities
quirky storytelling and the sheer drive
of the series to push boundaries much
akin to the characters themselves to
this day I don't think I've ever seen
anything quite like Gurren Lagann which
takes on such an epic journey but never
loses sight of its core ideas and I
can't tell you how many
I've watched the last episode of the
series specifically the first half with
the battle against the anti spirals it's
almost certainly over 100 times at least
I can tell you that much and it never
fails to captivate me it's one of those
things that I watch whenever I'm feeling
a bit down or need some inspiration or
if I'm just feeling neutral in general
to me it's an injection of life in
whatever situation calls for it a
reminder that I do have the drive to do
things and even if I'm feeling less than
confident about achieving them well I
should do them anyway that is the insane
impact that Gurren Lagann has had on my
life just by absorbing its core
philosophy it's that sort of artificial
confidence and realization that just
because you're uncertain or even afraid
of something doesn't necessarily mean
that you shouldn't do it and to sum up
some major decisions I made in regards
to that well it ranges from stuff like
deciding to leave home and going to
study theatre for three years straight
out of high school to the more mundane
stuff like having the courage to ask
someone out who I traditionally would
have been far too self-conscious to
approach but I have to say that the most
profound effect to title me is in every
aspect of my creative life I mean I
became a theatre designer because I
thought screw it why not give it a go
and did in more modern times I became a
youtuber because I saw it that seems fun
let's challenge myself and see if I can
break into that space and know it
doesn't always work out there are plenty
of things I've applied this to that have
failed some of them failed spectacularly
even but I definitely don't regret
trying because I believe I've lived a
significantly more rewarding life than I
would have if I hadn't gotten that boost
of optimism the Gurren Lagann hooks
straight into my veins at the age of 17
now with all of this said his Gurren
Lagann objectively the best anime series
of all time there's no real way to
measure that but probably not in fact
Gurren Lagann despite what I said in the
intro of this video isn't even my
favorite series of all time one piece is
just to clarify I'm talking about them
manga much more so than the anime you
can see anime problems you know it
doesn't have problems Gurren Lagann
beautiful enemy and look Gurren Lagann
hit me at a very vulnerable time and I
have no doubt that it was an incredible
influence on molding Who I am today and
you know I have met a lot of people who
have seen the series and they think it's
kind of mad and that's fine though
because those people each have their own
life shaping pieces of media that they
look to and if you have a series as
close to you as Gurren Lagann is to me
then please do drop it in the comments
because I'd love to know what pieces of
media or even just plain entertainment
inspire you and some
way and for all of you out there who has
something you want to do but it just do
timid to begin well just believe in the
me who believes in you because if I can
do it and I guarantee you that literally
anybody can but that pretty much does it
for how Gurren Lagann quite literally
changed my life if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video I like
share or subscribe because it also helps
sport this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time and please do head over to my
discourse over for a wide array of
Shannara takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts and Gurren Lagann this has been
the new world review and i'll see you
next time
you